COLT MCANLIS: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted a profusion of talks
detailing the future of Cloud.
If you didn't get a chance
to catch the session,
"Google's Identity as a
Service for GCP and G Suite,"
then stay tuned, because
here's the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you operate in a dual
world of on-premise and cloud,
you can use identity
as a service
to extend your
on-premise identity
process to your
cloud-based applications.
RETO MEIER: Google's
newly-announced identity
as a service offering,
Google Cloud Identity,
extends the cloud identity
solution used by G Suite
to all Google's
cloud-based products.
COLT MCANLIS: You don't have
to be a G Suite customer
to use cloud identity.
And Cloud Identity
makes managing
your non-Google
Cloud-based applications
simple with SSO and central
provisioning for administration
ease.
RETO MEIER: Cloud Identity
makes identity management
across your organization
consistent, secure,
and seamless.
To do so, it offers a
comprehensive cloud directory
that stores your users/groups,
devices, and applications
they can access, which syncs
with your on-premise directory.
COLT MCANLIS: It also
offers comprehensive access
management.
Now, your users work with
a variety of applications,
both local and cloud-based,
from a variety of organizations,
which means they're more
likely to reuse passwords
than remember different
ones for each app.
So you can use Cloud
Identity as a way
to keep things secure
without adding friction.
RETO MEIER: Finally, you
can use Cloud Identity
to set the right level of
authorization and access
control.
For example, you can require
that access to your payroll app
requires use of
two-factor authentication
every time with short
session token durations.
Both static conditions and
runtime dynamic conditions
are supported.
COLT MCANLIS: Of
course, everything
needs to be driven
by open standard,
so there is never an
issue with vendor lock-in.
Cloud Identity makes managing
your other cloud-based
applications simple.
SSO is supported as-is,
provisioning them centrally
for administration ease.
And if you're an
existing GCP customer,
it's really simple to
onboard enterprise identity
using Google's ID as a service.
RETO MEIER: What makes Google
a compelling Cloud Identity
provider is the robust
and secure infrastructure
that backs the service.
Based on our experience
running seven services
with a monthly active user
account of over a billion
users, we apply advanced
machine learning techniques
to identify threats
and design and build
custom hardened systems
from hardware, to networks,
to software.
This is the same
infrastructure that
supports Google's businesses.
While we don't support
legacy protocols,
we do work with trusted
partners like Okta and Ping
to enable an end-to-end
solution for our customers
that spans cloud and
hybrid-use cases.
Use Google's Cloud Identity and
Directory as your master source
to get the benefits of
Google's infrastructure
and use a recommended
partner to help bridge
between cloud and on-premise.
COLT MCANLIS: In all
cases, keeping your trust
is paramount.
Your data is always yours,
and Google will never
use your data for ads.
Cloud Identity meets compliance
and regulatory needs, including
various certifications.
And we publicly document
security best practices,
including employee background
checks, independent audit
processes, and more.
To see demos on how
to onboard identities
to GCP using ID as
a service and how
Netflix has used Google Identity
to help power their business,
check out the full
session video on YouTube.
And if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget the Next
World Tour, coming soon
to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]